[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo ravi de vous
retrouver pour un nouveau tour d'horizon
de l'actualité de la semaine dans le
département
tout de suite les titres de ce vendredi
18 janvier déplacement ministériel
aujourd'hui dans les yvelines à la zone
portuaire de limay brune poirson agnès
pannier-runacher et jean louis chaussade
ont signé le contrat stratégique de la
filière transformation et valorisation
des déchets objectif réduire de moitié
la mise en décharge et recyclé 100% des
plastiques à l'horizon 2025 de la
pâtisserie des chocolats mais avant tout
du caramel comme son nom l'indiqué le
cofondateur de l'entreprise basé à
guyancourt partira demain au salon du
chocolat de tokyo nicholas lewin sera
notre invité réunion pour l'organisation
du congrès annuel des enseignants
inauguration des nouveaux locaux
d'yveline numérique ou encore vente aux
enchères comme chaque vendredi coup
d'oeil sur l'actualité de la semaine
son pdg pourtant derrière les barreaux
mérono reste le constructeur automobile
français numéro un dans le monde
le groupe implanté dans les yvelines à
guyancourt et flins a réalisé 3,88
millions de ventes de véhicules en 2008
juste devant psa déplacement ministériel
aujourd'hui dans les yvelines le
gouvernement s'est fixé un objectif
réduire de moitié la mise en décharge et
recyclé 100% des plastiques d'ici 2025
pour s'en donner les moyens un contrat
dit stratégique de la filière
transformation et valorisation des
déchets a été signé ce vendredi matin
et pour cet engagement les secrétaires
d'état brune poirson et agnès pannier
rue nager ont fait le déplacement dans
une usine de traitement du plastique ça
se passe au port de limay le reportage
de grégory canal et cette usine traite
40 mille tonnes de bouteilles en
plastique chaque année dont une grande
partie au final recyclé pour le contact
alimentaire un site implanté dans la
zone portuaire de lyme est prise en
exemple par le gouvernement la
secrétaire d'état la transition
écologique et solidaire brune poirson et
son homologue à l'économie et aux
finances
agnès pannier rue nash et
sont rendus sur place elles ont signé
vendredi 18 janvier le contrat
stratégique de la filière transformation
et valorisation des déchets c'est très
difficile de recycler et de fabriquer
des atrides de faire du plastique qui
est compatible avec un usage et avec un
contact alimentaire est ça la france fr
une usine comme celle ci le prouve ici
le déchet est une ressource et qu'en
fait à terme l'objectif c'est que on ne
parle plus de déchet mais bien de
ressources
donc il ya un enjeu qui à la fois très
industrielle un enjeu qui est très
écologique
il ya un enjeu qui est très sociale en
termes d'emploi pour développer cette
filière de la transformation et de la
valorisation des déchets le contrat fixe
six projets structurants notamment
l'accompagnement des acteurs du secteur
et du potentiel de recyclage accélérer
la robotisation des centres de tri ou
encore développer l'offre de formation
et de certification
la problématique c'est de se dire
comment mettons nous en place des
filières industrielles rentable puisque
on a mis en place à technologie après
faut mettre en place le reste et en même
temps de mettre en place tout
l'écosystème qui a été décrit par les
deux ministres à savoir
l'éco construction la capacité d'avoir
des produits qu'ils soient recyclables
etc etc etc
il ya toute une série de choses qu'il
faut mettre en place si on veut
véritablement que ces filières démarre
en 2015 en france 3 124,5 millions de
tonnes de déchets ont été produits 75%
de détritus ménagers ont été valorisés
retour également sur les voeux
d'alexandra rosetti maire de
voisins-le-bretonneux en présence de
maires des communes voisines mais aussi
gérard larcher président du sénat et
jean michel fourgous président de saint
quentin en yvelines
alexandra rose et y est revenu sur
l'année 2018 et ses travaux
d'investissements avec notamment la
restauration de l'église ou encore la
maison du mes rentes et où se sont
déroulés hier soir les voeux des
investissements dans le domaine sportif
également voisins le bretonneux a reçu
le label ville active et sportives
durant la cérémonie des voeux les
problèmes de circulation et la polémique
du contournement ont été évoqués la mer
créera une aire de covoiturage au champ
du loup autre point sensible la création
d'un nouveau cimetière
l'actuel arrive à saturation s'étend des
projets de la commune pour cette année
2010 9
écoutez la mer on à la création d'un
nouveau cimetière qui est un sujet un
peu sensible lui aussi tout un plan de
réfection de voirie pour améliorer la
sécurité des piétons pour essayer
d'encourager les cyclistes à les
emprunter on a quelques beaux projets de
logements aussi on a 95 logements
à la manivelle avec une résidence
intergénérationnelle on a notre bien sûr
notre fameux écoquartier de la remise
aussi qui va vraiment démarrer la propre
très prochainement défrichage va
commencer le nouveau big rose va être
construit et puis on a un autre quartier
on a aussi 110 logements la grande île
on a des petits programmes de logements
centre ville voilà tout ça va nous
permettre d'accueillir de nouvelles
familles direction en guyane en cours à
présent avec la société et caramel
nicholas lewin vous est le cofondateur
bonjour bonjour moi non votre spécialité
comme le nom de votre entreprise
l'indiquent le caramel et sous toutes
ses formes en délicieuses petites
bouchées aux mille parfums en caramel à
tartiner hambach en coffret ou encore
rentable et de chocolat et vous partez
demain pendant deux semaines direction
le japon pour le salon du chocolat
cette première participation le deuxième
c'est la deuxième on a fait l'édition
déjà 2018 et c'était un succès on a été
on était un petit peu pris d'assaut donc
donc c'est super et bien sûr on n'a pas
d'atelier au japon donc impossible de
reproduire
donc cette année on a produit plus pour
pouvoir contenter le plus de japonais et
japonaises possible voilà donc excité
parce que demain un départ on clôture un
mois et demi de production spécialement
pour eux est ce que ça représente quand
même des palettes de chocolat et de
caramel donc
donc voilà qu'on arrive presque presque
au meilleur moment
et justement donc deuxième participation
en quoi cette importance est deuxième
fois pour vous c'est important parce que
ça nous permet de médecins un pied à
l'étranger
on a déjà une boutique à paris et on a
déjà pas mal de clients japonais
donc le fait de se déplacer là-bas de
rencontrer nos clients nous met un pied
dans l'asie donc c'est important et on
commence à être un petit peu connue
là-bas donc
donc on a attendu donc voilà parce que
l'idée c'est quand même d'essayer de se
développer à l'étranger
donc pour nous c'est une vitrine sur la
vie extraordinaire
alors on le fait avec plaisir et le
chocolat une place importante dans la
gastronomie japonaise
oui alors c'est une bonne question le
chocolat en fait le chocolat c'est
essentiellement en l'offre là bas au
moment de wade et donc qui est un petit
peu la saint-valentin japonaise et c'est
le moment de l'année où le japonais
achètent du chocolat voilà les autres
fait ces différences et c'est pas
forcément c'est plus des pâtisseries
japonaise mais mes whitehead et donc qui
est au mois de février
c'est le moment où tout le monde en fait
fait ses emplettes là-bas pour offrir un
petit cadeau et c'est souvent du
chocolat voilà et dont vous connaissez
un petit peu le japonais il adore
l'innovation il adore la création il
faut sans cesse innover sans cesse crée
donc dès qu'on est un petit peu jeune et
qu'on amène quelque chose de nouveau
souvent ça fonctionne donc on a la
chance pour cette deuxième édition de
participer et qu'elle et vous proposer à
cette édition du salon du chocolat fait
nous saliver un petit peu alors on a
plusieurs types de produits alors
toujours à base de caramel
l'idée étant d'avoir un clin d'oeil au
caramel si ce n'est un caramel complet
donc on a des caramels à tartiner qui se
trouvent dans ses pots donc là on a une
collection de neuf caramel des caramels
offrit des caramels aux épices des
caramels classique aussi des très
gourmand très agressif on a aussi le
bonbon traditionnelle en papillote donc
la décliner également sous une dizaine
de sortes
donc l'idée étant aussi de surprendre et
d'apporter des choses nouvelles
donc on peut retrouver un caramel au blé
noir donc le sahara un caramel à la
framboise travailler à partir de
fruit directement voilà ensuite on a
également une collection de chocolats
donc des petites barques à rames elysées
avec à l'intérieur des caramels de
différentes sortes caramel noix de pécan
caramel fruits rouges caramel vanille
fleur de sel à l'intérieur du chocolat
et ensuite on a une collection de on les
a baptisés les petites ligues avec des
nouilles gatineau sésame dénoue gâtine
noix de coco le tout enrobé de chocolat
voilà donc on essaye vraiment de on
essaye de créer d'apporter quelque chose
d'inédit et vous proposer des mets
exclusif pour ce salon du chocolat
oui pour le salon du chocolat alors on a
créé un caramel en exclusivité qui a un
caramel chocolat et fèves de tonka
donc l'idée étant d'associer le thème
quand même du déplacement le chocolat le
caramel et la fève de tonka qui est
méconnu en fait déjà en france assez
méconnu mais ce qu'au japon vraiment qui
est une petite fève que l'on utilise
comme un aromate en fait convient râpé
et qui est très odorante et qui nous
rappelle un petit peu le côté boisé du
bois mouillé
c'est un petit peu c'est original donc
c'est là une création exclusive pour le
japon et on a également réalisé une
ganache avec un miel
un miel que j'ai forcé dans les pyrénées
qui est un miel de callune c'est une
bruyère qui pousse à mi hauteur
voilà dans les pyrénées on essaye de
mettre à l'honneur aussi des petits
artisans et des producteurs locaux
dans cette société de miel avec qui on
travaille maintenant et un de vos mets
exclusif l'enrobage de praliné au sésame
noir que vous allez proposer pour le
salon du chocolat de tokyo votre chef
pâtissier nous a livré vos petits
secrets de fabrication regardez là on a
réalisé le premier mais ensuite on a
détaillé
en forme rectangulaire et ensuite on le
robes de chocolat et on décore avec des
peines de 7 à moi je mets le tapis en
route
les bonbons de chocolat vont passer sous
le sur le rideau de chocolat ici donc un
chocolat qui a une température exacte de
trempage
ou d'un enrobage de chocolat essoufflé
ici pour enlever l'excédent de chocolat
et ensuite à la sortie on met le décor
du du bonbon alors selon vous pourquoi
les japonais sont-ils friands de vaud
délice je pense qu'il ya eu déjà il ya
le côté français côté français fait le
made in france fait rêver et je pense
que maintenant il ya beaucoup de
français qui sont implantés là bas on
est un petit peu une valeur sûre en
terme de en termes de gourmandise et de
gastronomie française antoine mondiale
donc je pense que l'on rassure
et puis je pense que le côté exclusif
nouveaux jeunes un peu frère qui arrive
parmi des institutions telles que
patrick roger jean paul hévin qui sont
installés depuis des années là bas au
japon suscite un petit peu la curiosité
effet qu' on a envie d'essayer
voilà et c'est là où faut être bon parce
que essayer c'est bien mais il faut il
faut il faut concrétiser les c'est parce
que il faut que ce soit bon quoi parce
que si le japonais achètent nos produits
qui sont vendus très chers au japon
beaucoup plus cher qu'en france ce que
vous imaginez que s'est produit en
france et transporté au japon il faut
que le produit soit excellent et
irréprochable parce que sinon on perd
cette clientèle donc on fera si on n'est
pas bon on fera pas de troisième salon
du chocolat est justement une marque de
noblesse vous avez travaillé chez
ladurée en tant que chef pâtissier
international et vous avez lancé en
début d'année 2016 votre entreprise
caramel votre atelier est à guyancourt
et votre boutique se situe à paris d'où
vous provient cette passion depuis tout
jeune j'ai démarré juin en normandie
je suis issu d'une famille gourmande
j'ai de la famille haussier dans le
métier donc j'ai été piqué très jeune et
puis arrivé à 20 ans 21 ans je me suis
dit enfin je sentais qu'il fallait que
je bouge de la normandie fallait que
j'aille voir la capitale et j'ai répondu
à une annonce tout simplement et je suis
entré chez ladurée et j'avais 21 ans et
je suis resté vivant voilà donc fidèle
j'ai évolué on m'a fait confiance
c'est une très belle maison qui se
développer à l'étranger
j'ai eu la chance de participer de
participer au développement et puis
voilà est arrivé à 30 ans je me suis dit
que c'était bon moment pour moi sur
autre chose et donc j'écris quand même
eh bien on espère que vous représenterez
au mieux la france au salon du chocolat
de tokyo merci nicolas leoz d'avoir été
avec nous je le rappelle vous est le
cofondateur de l'entreprise caramel
[Musique]
dernière journée de réunion aujourd'hui
pour l'organisation du congrès annuel
d'à j'ai eu m
l'association générale des enseignants
des écoles et classes maternelles
publiques
chaque année le congrès se déroule dans
une ville différente et pour ce 92ème
congrès il se déroulera à port marly
dans l'académie de versailles
reportage le port marly sera la ville où
se tiendra le 92ème congrès national de
la gm
l'association générale des enseignants
des écoles et classes maternelles
publiques
elle a été créée en 1921 elle a été
créée à vichy par un groupe
d'enseignants tu vois là dès qu'ils se
sont réunis parce qu'il y avait déjà une
inégalité de salaires
à cette époque et les collègues se sont
regroupés autour de cette association
pour faire la promotion de l'école
maternelle pour défendre les intérêts
des enseignants et défendre les intérêts
des enfants en comité restreint tous
réfléchissent à l'organisation du
congrès annuel pour promouvoir l'école
maternelle et en particulier la
thématique des arts c'est un véritable
moment où bat le coeur de la maternelle
et où les enseignants qui viennent là
c'est en même temps pour se ressourcer
pour partager et au sein de l'académie
de versailles
tous ceux qui ont travaillé depuis
depuis trois ans et offrir ce moment et
ses espaces pour se retrouver et parler
de la maternelle qui est nôtre
voilà notre passion il met au point
l'organisation des expositions
pédagogiques mais aussi toute la
logistique
pendant trois jours ils établissent le
programme précis des journées du congrès
un rendez vous très attendu pour les
enseignantes passionnant de pouvoir
rencontrer ce qui est fait par les
autres collègues échanger avec les
autres collègues sur ce qu'elles font
leurs pratiques de classe et cet échange
là est source de formation pour nous
mille deux cents personnes sont
attendues au congrès il se déroulera du
3 au 5 juillet 2019 aux pyramides à
port-marly de nouveaux locaux pour
yvelines numériques le syndicat les
intégrer l'été dernier à guyancourt
l'inauguration officielle s'est déroulée
hier matin en présence de plusieurs élus
locaux
evelyne numérique est en charge
notamment du déploiement de la fibre
optique sur tout le territoire à
l'horizon 2020 le reportage d'aurélie
rose et marylène iapichino dans sa
politique de déploiement du numérique le
département des yvelines ans et en 2016
yvelines numériques un regroupement du
département et des intercommunalités en
un syndicat mixte ouvert chargé du
développement des plateformes numériques
de service public
on travaille dans de domaine
essentiellement le numérique pour
l'éducation et nous déployons donc des
outils au bénéfice des élèves dès que
des parents d'élèves et de l'ensemble de
la communauté éducative notamment les
enseignants et nous travaillons
également dans le domaine de la sûreté
électronique où nous développons une
plateforme innovante qui permet de faire
remonter en temps réel
un nombre d'image d'un très grand nombre
de sites un service de vidéo protection
déployée dans tous les collèges du
département
des robots dans les hôpitaux ou les
domiciles pour maintenir le contact
entre l'école et les enfants de nombreux
projets en cours de développement
c'était important de bénéficier de
locaux qui permettent justement tout ce
développement et qui permettent de se
concentrer de travailler en groupe de
recevoir des partenaires du conseil
départemental de versailles yvelines
numériques a donc déménagé à guyancourt
dans ses nouveaux locaux plus modernes
et fonctionnels pour remplir sa mission
haut débit fin 2020 l'ensemble du haut
débit sera déployé dans la zone blanche
du département des yvelines de deux
façons choix par l'installation de la
fibre numérique choix parce qu'on
appelle la montée en débit c'est à dire
qu on équipe les réseaux téléphoniques
existants de systèmes qui permettent
d'augmenter leur puissance pour faire
passer plus d'image cette journée
d'inauguration est également marquée par
le lancement du nouveau site internet du
syndicat mixte ouvert autre
rassemblement hier une journée d'
expertise gratuite était organisée par
un hôtel de ventes aux enchères parisien
les versailles et avait la possibilité
de faire expertiser leurs bijoux
tableaux ou autres trésors que l'on se
transmet de génération en génération
aurélie rose donner une valeur et une
opinion sur l'authenticité d'un bijou
d'un tableau bien d'un objet d'art
voici le principe de cette journée d'
expertise gratuite
exceptionnellement canaliser ce jeudi 17
janvier à versailles
nous sommes une maison de vente aux
enchères donc on
organise des journées des expertises et
des ventes aux enchères à la fois à lyon
dans notre hôtel des ventes et à paris
les expertises se font dans nos bureaux
dans le 6e et les ventes à l'hôtel
drouot
ça doit valoir entre j'avais quelques
objets de
dans j'ignorais la valeur voulais
préciser les choses dans ses peurs pour
leur régler des successions pour l'est
les partages à mes hommes et enfants
succession inventaire pour assurance ou
gestion d'une collection d'art les
raisons sont multiples pour venir faire
estimer son objet gilone a apporté des
bijoux appartenant à ses ancêtres des
broches un portable selon elle et qui
l'encombré j'ai une estimation pour
chaque chaque pièce et on verra on verra
si c'est sa part apple sommes prudents
les 500 euros chaque objet oui à peu
près oui je ne serais même pas tant vous
voyez pas ce que cherche des bijoutiers
ont proposé rien du tout les bijoux de
givonne seront vendues aux enchères le
20 février prochain à paris en mode
culture à présent vous pourrez vous
rendre ce week-end à la galerie sans
simon de versailles l'artiste corinne
cesca présente plusieurs de ces
monotypes des oeuvres réalisées autour
du corps humain du mouvement à découvrir
jusqu'au 27 janvier le reportage de
mélanie poker
des corps humains sensuelle qui semble
poser des peintures monotype corinne csk
travaille sur une plaque de métal sont
gravure créant des modèles inédits des
oeuvres réalisées grâce à une vie presse
artisanale
je travaille sur les émotions
en fait ce qui est ce que mon c'est la
diversité des émotions et je passe par
le corps je cherche un langage sur le
monotype pour un langage pour exprimer
dans le corps sur les inversions de deux
hanches la puissance de l'émotion aussi
en essayant de par exemple de partir à
un pied propulser la tête
corinne cesca découvre son amour pour
l'art en 2006 une pratique tardive qui
passe par un envoûtement une révélation
les stands plus permet une possibilité
infinie de création c'est la technique
du monotype qui m'a
complètement séduit parce qu'on
travaille sur une plaque de métal on
peut enlever rajouter gratter ses on
peut tout faire en une feuille de papier
gratté par dessus j'ai un plaisir du
geste aussi quand il ya des rythmes on
peut partir de dans le mouvement c'est
la puissance ces deux mois qu'il faut
que je l'inscrivent coiffure inscrits ce
qui me vient comme comme émotion sur ma
plaque un art exutoire pour l'artiste
corinne c'est ce qu'a exposé ces trois
dernières années de création
[Musique]
l'actualité dans le rest d'ile-de-france
avec nos confrères devient grand paris
chaîne disponible sur la tnt et je vous
propose aujourd'hui de découvrir le
grand paris avec une mini série elle
vous permet d'explorer les lieux
emblématiques de la métropole
à travers des témoignages regarder le
grand paris comme si vous y étiez
une mini série à chacun chacune son
grand paris vous permet d'explorer les
lieux emblématiques de la métropole à
travers des témoignages
le projet a été confié à wilfrid duval
lauréats 2016 du meilleur court métrage
grand paris au festival megacity
chandhok un parisien pure souche
l'idée voilà c'était vraiment d'aller au
delà de la métropole institutionnels
dont qui est paris et la petite couronne
partir d'un usage du territoire d'un
individu d'une histoire
et de raconter cette histoire pour
susciter chez les personnes qui vont
regarder les vidéos d'ébats un
imaginaire du grand paris se dire ok
quand je vais à saint denis quand je
vais à saclay quand je vais à l'aéroport
et ben je suis dans le grand paris il se
passe des choses et des gens qui font
des choses ici qui travaillent qui
habite qui vive
et tout ça c'est le grand paris tout cet
ensemble c'est le grand paris le
réalisateur a posé sa caméra dans des
endroits connus comme rungis où la
défense mais aussi plus surprenant comme
une académie de cirque en
seine-saint-denis où un tunnelier du
grand paris le premier épisode nous
propose de découvrir la place un centre
de culture hip hop
extraits la place est un lieu
particulier parce que c'est le premier
lieu
j'ai trouvé pour venir danser qu'on est
là on peut danser on a des quand même un
gros temps de danse on a de 13h à 19h
ouverture face monde donc non
franchement je trouve que c'est parfait
on nous laisse dans ces a pas de souci
on est libre cette mini série web qui
compte 22 épisodes est diffusée chaque
mardi
elle est à découvrir depuis le 4
décembre sur le site de la mairie de
paris
paris.fr chaque semaine nous ouvrons nos
archives pour revenir sur l'actualité
locale
aujourd'hui nous revenons sur la
première élection du maire de saint cyr
bernard de bain qui ne se représentera
pas pour un mandat en 2020
[Musique]
voici enfin le nouveau visage aux
commandes de la ville bernard de bain
tout juste promu conseiller municipal en
lieu et place de philippe lavaud prend
donc la direction de saint cyr l'école
élu au premier tour de scrutin avec 17
voix à la majorité absolue
une tâche qui s'annonce ardue face à une
opposition revendicative
alors que la majorité apparaît plus que
jamais divisée moi je suis un homme
d'écouté de dialogue
donc de toute façon je pense que si on
veut arriver à gérer cette ville on peut
pas le faire avec une opposition
systématique est le seul moyen de de
pouvoir la gérer avec l'opposition c'est
de l'associer à nos travaux la première
action du nouveau maire sera sans doute
de rallier les cinq dissidents de la
liste saint cyr à venir à sa cause c'est
un conseiller dont gaétan desjardins
ancienne première adjointe exclu par le
groupe majoritaire pour avoir contesté
les méthodes de philippe lavaud moi
effectivement je n'étais pas toujours
d'accord avec monsieur lavaud
j'étais d'accord sur les projets puisque
c'étaient nos projets lorsque nous avons
été élus je n'étais pas d'accord sur les
méthodes
moi j'aime la rigueur la transparence la
concertation la discussion
la dictature je n'aime pas beaucoup
candidate de l'opposition brigitte
berthomieu réclamé quant à elle la
démission générale du conseil afin de
provoquer de nouvelles élections auprès
des saint-cyriens il nous dit j'assume
j'assume tout le passé les mandats
l'équipe l'équipe ac avait un mandat des
saint cyriens mans je n'ai pas
l'impression quand même que le mandat
qui avait été donnée à part les saint
cyriens l'équipe municipale étaient les
illégalités les crises
les déchirements qui nous donne quelques
explications sur la situation financière
de la ville
le chantier s'annonce donc laborieux
entre l'hypothétique annulation de la
vente de la gendarmerie
tout le dossier épineux de la piscine à
zéro euro
quoi qu'il en soit bernard de bain
semble être l'homme du dialogue retrouvé
plusieurs conseillers d'opposition
déclarant hier à l'auditoire ne plus
être habitué depuis longtemps à temps de
concertation
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo retour
de l'information dans le 7-8 journal dès
18h lundi passé un excellent week-end
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on